buenos días para todos ustedes buenas
tardes desde londres les cuento que el
primer ministro en salir del gabinete de
boris johnson es el ministro de
educación
gavin williamson altamente criticado por
su pobre gestión para millones de niños
en todo el país en la educación que se
han perdido de las clases presenciales
así que ha sido el primero en ser
anunciado como descabezado de este
gabinete ha dicho en su cuenta de
twitter que ha sido un privilegio servir
como ministro de educación a pesar de
una pandemia global este será el primer
cambio en el gabinete de boris johnson
en los últimos 18 meses y se da un día
después de que el gobierno anunciara su
estrategia para el cob y 19 durante el
invierno veremos a lo largo de la tarde
los anuncios progresivos de quienes se
van quienes llegan y quienes se
mantienen en el gabinete de boris
johnson desfilando por las afueras de
dawn instruido en el parlamento
británico